thank you for the introduction thank you
for inviting me to the seminar and for
the warm welcome their lovely
conversations I've had this morning
already and the plan for the rest of the
day so uh I
thank you for the intro mostly for kind
of maybe making sure everybody was ready
for something different
uh I love talking to Broad audiences
about my work and
um about the value of design research
and research through design and so I'm
more than happy to answer questions if
you're kind of like what are we talking
about what is going on I love more of a
kind of interactive ask question as we
go type of talk and so if you're feeling
like you don't know what's going on just
let me know
um yeah so I'll
um maybe to help you understand why I do
what I do and how I got here I'll give
you just a little bit of a trajectory
for how I got there so I was born in
Montreal I am French Canadian and so if
some of the words are a little funny
that's because of that and I studied
industrial design as my undergraduate
degree so I was thinking about how do we
make physical things for people and then
I worked for a little bit as an
industrial designer in Montreal but then
I had so many questions about what
happens when some of these physical
things
have computation get in them you know
like 2008 is when the iPhone came out
and so there was kind of all all of a
sudden this idea that you could have a
computer on you at all time for anything
and any anything and everything and it
just kind of really opened up my
imagination and I was like okay we need
to ask questions about what that means
for us so I moved to Vancouver BC so
from the East Coast over to the West
Coast
um to start a masters in interaction
design so moving from industrial design
which is very much concerned about the
physical to more questions about the
digital side of things and that's where
I learned what design research was which
is basically you can use design to ask
questions which is kind of what I was
doing you know this is why I got there
um and then also learned that you can
actually do a PhD in that and so I
decided to stay and do a PhD and
graduated at the school of interactive
Arts and Technology and then really
loved the west coast and didn't quite
want to go back home and so I applied to
an assistant professor job at University
of Washington in Seattle
and moved down there
where the cherry blossoms are not quite
there yet this season this is an old
photo we are very much in the rain right
now and so everybody's been apologizing
to me about the rain here and I'm like
yeah don't mention it it's okay
um and so there yeah I started in the
school of art art history and design and
I do have a courtesy appointment in hcde
which is human centered design and
Engineering very much core to the HDI
community on campus as well as in the
dxarts department which is the digital
and experimental
um our media and art art and media
um department so I really kind of have
kind of this this position where I can
use Art and Design as a way to
interrogate technology and so a lot of
what I'm going to present today is in
that space
okay who's heard of research through
design
research to design is a methodology
where basically you use design as a mode
of inquiry this is your main approach to
design many of you might know you know
your
um trying to understand different needs
different contexts and then you're
making an intervention you're ideating
you're kind of thinking about what could
we make to change the situation and then
through the making you're discovering
things you're learning usually then like
that thing goes on and like exists in
the world in design research we're using
that thing to figure out new new ideas
new knowledge
so at Studio tilt um so it's a designer
research Studio it's hosted at the
school of art art history and design and
as a studio we question and reimagine
familiar encounters between humans and
things
pretty broad statement but this is kind
of you know like if I'm trying to
explain what it is that we do it's
really this both the questioning so it's
critical it's really about kind of
wondering why are things the way they
are and then it's also trying to think
well if we're not satisfied with what
they are what else could they be
um Our intention is not to design the
next consumer product so a lot of people
are like okay so then like that's going
to be sold at Best Buy you know next
year and I'm like no
um the goal is really to reflect to
critique and to imagine Alternatives and
then in small sure eventually our hope
is that we you know are leading to
better more fair more appropriate more
relevant better for people better for
the planet products but our you know the
step before that is to kind of be in
that critical space
okay title of the talk today data
imaginaries and so of course in the
context of um Studio tilt we're in here
trying to reimagine and so we're not
trying to reimagine data although maybe
a little bit we're really trying to
reimagine how is it that we encounter
data
well what everybody when's the last time
you encountered data that you like saw
or met or felt or were with data
weather up this morning okay yes saw
data on an app
looked at it decided it was gonna rain
right any other ones
when's the last time you saw data yeah I
used my body skill this morning oh yeah
okay so dedicated device looked at the
weight then you're like yes
[Laughter]
there's like different ways we see data
in our everyday lives still if I ask you
what does data look like maybe that's
what you're thinking of right if you
look in Google you type data Google
search image why is it that we always
think data in this kind of similar way
you know we have all these interactions
and yet like the way that movies are
showing it to us the anytime there's
like a news article about data there's
like this weird graphic at the top and
that's what we see and so that
frustrates me as a designer I'm like
what what else could it be why does it
have to be that and what are the dangers
of just having that the real danger is
that we have a homogeneous view of what
data are and by extension of what they
can do and so if we're able to broaden
what data are what they look like or
what they feel like maybe we can start
to think about other ways of using or
being with data that are potentially
less connected to some of the things
that maybe we don't want so much
capitalism perhaps
surveillance perhaps privacy questions
questions of agency and so these are the
kinds of things that I'm trying to kind
of shake up a little bit with the work
that I'm doing
okay
in the same vein if I ask you what is
data these are some of the words that
you might think are connected to data
it's usually digital it doesn't have a
real material sense
it may feel objective and true it may
seem homogeneous and it can also feel
Universal and clean okay
you can see that there's a white space
next to that that's because I want to
get to this other list like what's the
alternative right and so before that I
think what's important to remember is
that the system in which data are
created so the glass incline wrote this
really beautiful book data feminism I
really do recommend it to all of you
um where they say this extractive system
create which is like the system of kind
of capturing and collecting and creating
data creates a profound asymmetry an
imbalance between who is collecting
storing analyzing data and whose data
are actually collected stored and
analyzed the power is really really
strong on the one side that people were
actually able to analyze the data and
yet or the companies very often right
and then the people who actually produce
all that data and so when we're trying
to shift that to bring back power to
people who are creating data well maybe
we can get to another list
what if we considered data as local as
opposed to it everywhere what if it's
Lively what you know it has its own life
what if it becomes heterotaneous it has
all these different forms what if as
opposed to being kind of the Standalone
thing it really becomes part of an
assemblage right it becomes part of the
people that created it of the local like
the context that created it
what if we look at it from a personal
perspective from an interpretive for
interpretative point of view as opposed
for it to be completely objective we
know that there is human actions
throughout the process of gathering data
well
that's interpretation throughout so like
let's actually be honest about it maybe
and agree that that's there and maybe
instead of Big Data let's think about
small data for a minute
okay I know these are not one to one and
they are not meant to be I'm just kind
of thinking about two lists of kind of
adjectives to think about data
Okay so
but I feel that my pitch by focusing on
the more human qualities of data if we
think about small data small data calls
for reducing the gap between those
creating the data and how it may be
understood right thinking back at that
um quote from data feminism and so small
data just be clear doesn't mean complete
opposite of Big Data instead small data
are intricately linked to the large
ecosystems of Big Data data economy and
surveillance but where attention is
focused on the personal relationship so
by doing that I'm not saying we're
ignoring all the other links that data
have I'm just saying what would happen
if we focused on those personal links
just for a minute
or maybe for the rest of the hour
um so that's the question I'm asking how
my creative data representations support
other engagements with data we're
looking at those Alternatives we're
trying to reimagine
okay you looked at the data app you
looked at the weight scale sometimes it
might look like this a spread really
long spreadsheet of things sometimes
it's a it's a you know quick
visualization sometimes it's a dashboard
another dashboard another dashboard uh
I'm looking these are all from
um smart home devices a lot of my work
is in the context of Home context of iot
Internet of Things devices and so okay
like you might also even have your
fridge that's do you know this was a
really funny thread by Dan Han who said
WTF our fridge just emailed us to say we
opened the door too many times this past
month like if this is your engagement
with data granted this is pretty funny
but it's funny because it's weird wait
okay I also like weird but
um is this what we want
is this where we're going
I hope not you know okay so
I have about four or five projects I
want to talk about today
um that are all trying to cast data in a
really different way really trying to
you know go against this basically just
trying to see like what's gonna happen
if we don't do that instead do something
else
so um I'll go through them relatively
quickly because I want to be able to
show you the variety of projects but I
also invite questions kind of along the
way so the first one is the listening
cups I'll pass them around These are 3D
printed Ceramics
um they are
cups so you can wash them or you can
drink from them
and the bumps on them are representing
sound and so the question we were asking
was or the goal really was how do we
reveal ignore or hidden data in everyday
domestic iot artifacts through
physicalization right so for those of
you who might not know physicalization
is the idea of transforming data into a
physical
representation of that data material so
it's very you know it's kind of in
contrast perhaps with visualizations
which use the 2D space to look at data
and so now we're engaging other senses
because we're using it you know 3D
object that also has kind of a weight
and the texture and all that
okay so the data started in a
spreadsheet okay
um basically we CA this was a very short
project it was a one week residency with
Tim yatihani who owns slip rabbit Studio
which is a ceramic studio in Seattle
um where she does both slip casting
which is one mode of um fabricating with
Ceramics but also has a 3D printer and
was really interested in kind of
starting to play with data in the
printer and so we captured eight short
clips of different kind of everyday
environments and so these two were my
home at night some nights are quieter
than others apparently and so there's
this there was a couple that were like
on the street a couple that were in a
restaurant some of them at the studio
also and so we had these captures and we
were then wondering okay well what does
it mean to translate that into a cup
um
and so here's the challenge
because how do you transform
kind of a linear scale to texture
and so it's pretty you know kind of the
first thing you might think about is
let's do the version here on the left
so basically a quiet noise would make a
small bump and then a louder noise would
make a larger bump right that's pretty
kind of obvious and so that's what we
did in the left one so you know these
milliseconds is actually how long the
printer pauses and so the longer it
pauses the more Clay is coming out
making a bigger bump at that moment on
the 3D printer and so that aligns with
the decibel level
so okay fair so we did that we did these
cups we looked at them we're like okay
and but then we of course asked well
what else can we do and so we wondered
what if instead we were trying to
showcase
kind of human voice in those recordings
and so human uh tone is usually around
60 to 65 decibels and so we made the
other score or we said anything below 60
is going to be really kind of tiny tiny
little bumps and then anything on these
uh above 65 maybe it's gonna also be
super small so anything that is a round
voice level that's going to be the big
bumps and so this is the same data those
two cups
they're clearly not the same
and so that's where I think that's the
first this is one of the first projects
I did with um data physicalization and
really working with data and the
realization of how much agency the
designer or the artist has in choosing
what
like kind of creating the boundaries for
what meaning is created of the data is
really powerful it's a really big amount
of power that you have when you're
choosing how do you kind of make those
translations those transformations
um and so of course we kind of played
with it and we were like okay well
sometimes perhaps it becomes really easy
to think about the stories that are
coming out of these cups right like when
is the morning happening you know when
is the alarm coming on maybe this is
clear when this is happening right like
all of a sudden everything is pretty
loud
um but sometimes it's more confusing so
this is one of the cups that's moving
around
what what event do you think produce
that
a yelling match yeah a big fight maybe
what else could it be
big party yeah
sorry what
oh and I'm balanced passing by yeah it
was pretty loud
what else uh-huh
oh yeah could it beep I think someone
one time told me like there was a tiger
and I was like what
like where do you think I live but okay
um okay actually this was the printer's
fault
there was a little bit of clay that got
or a little piece of hay that was caught
in the clay and so of course as the
printer's pushing it down the clay was
kind of obstructing the nozzle and so
nothing was coming out so when you look
at the at that cup look at the pieces
that are right before the bumps are like
not the same as the rest so like the
clay wasn't coming out wasn't coming out
and then like we pulled it off and like
all the clay came out because the
pressure had built up
and so this is my favorite example
because the stories we think we tell
with data also come from how we produce
the visualizations or the
physicalizations in this case right we
can't
dissociate the instrument of producing
the data physicalization from the actual
story or the meaning that's coming
through and so of course that's an
extreme example but every you know and
everything else that you're reading is
also kind of now part of you know why or
part of how this printer works
okay so this project really
foregrounded tactality as opposed to
visual approach to understanding data
and so now I have these cups I drink tea
out of them you know multiple times a
week and every time I drink tea you know
you I can't help but like you know keep
on touching the little bumps and
wondering like what actually happened in
that moment that created that bump and
so this totality allows for potentially
this like longer
um
uh engagement with meaning making and
data and then of course the data stories
how are they produced how do we know how
to trace back so that we make sense of
the story right like is it the printer
was it the yelling match or a tiger or
whatever whatever it was
um and so these are kind of some of the
two insights there uh also the other cup
that's going around that you saw if
you're comparing both of them you'll see
that we went through a lot of aesthetic
calibration for this project so the
shorter one is kind of chunkier looks
like a knit kind of and we felt like
that didn't allow for as much reading of
the data as the the one the ones that
you see here that are like a little bit
more fine and that look a little bit
more like a weave as a way
um and so I'm happy to talk a lot more
about kind of this like long kind of
slow process of fine tuning for how do
you and which is like a pretty
subjective approach to like what what's
the right thing to do here
okay questions about the cups before I
move on to the next project
you want to see the next one
okay all right the next one is the data
epics
so the data epics is a collection of 28
stories
um which I'll maybe start some here and
I'll start somewhere there uh the data
epics here instead of going with
um
uh uh something really material like the
cups we instead chose to think about
fiction
as a way to
render data
and so or to make this kind of creative
data representation and so basically
what this project is is it's really
leaning into the idea that there is
interpretation happening when you're
translating data
and so if we agree on that what happens
if you push further what happens if you
really push into this kind of
interpretative side of reading through
data and so we worked with seven fiction
writers in the Seattle area and seven
different households who lived in their
homes with different
um devices
iot devices so we had like a Peloton
bike multiple voice assistants
door sensors garage door opener camera
um
thermostat
Sonos range of everyday objects that are
kind of collect data and so what we
would do is we would ask the households
to collect their data for a month
send it to us we would anonymize it and
clean it a little bit so this is from a
voice assistant this is from a Smart
Switch
um and so basically we would clean it a
little to make it a little bit more
readable so remove some of the metadata
so this is from a voice assistant you
can see some of the questions
um how much are plane tickets to England
and then how do you rob a bank uh okay
lots of people ask different things to
voice assistance is what we learned from
that but
um they knew this was going to fiction
writers so I think they were playing a
little
so who knows who knows if they were
really asking or if they were playing
with the author which is part of the
interpretation side of things but
um so we cleaned it when the the data
was numerical we made simple
visualizations as a way to help with the
fiction writers and kind of just look at
the data so already so this is
thermostat over a whole month so what
happened here on March 6th and 7
maybe they're out of town I don't know
and then here this is a
um bedside
lamp that was in a smart plug and so I
think you know it looks like this person
is usually kind of getting around to
getting ready for bed around nine turns
off the light kind of around 10 but you
know what happens here you know January
3rd 3 A.M
something happened so okay
so already you we we can kind of make
stories out of these right so of course
fiction writers they have a much broader
imagination than us in a different one
we give them this they go on and analyze
the data out in whichever way they want
um write a story send it to us we typed
set it we make the books then we send
the books back to our participants who
now read their data in the form of a
book
um and so I'll it's really hard to
understand this project if you don't
read the story so I encourage you to
read as I'm talking
um but also which I rarely say but okay
um this is one excerpt so this is
elimination and this is the story that
is building on that bedside lamp
um visualization that I just showed
that's how it starts
she is born in darkness the absence of
light does not bother her nor does it
confuse her coming alive with the
imperative of most living things to move
she does at speeds almost
incomprehensible she rushes off as
quickly as she can determined not to be
a laggard
only knowing that she has a destination
she must get to she does not yet know
what that destination is only that she
must get to it in quickly
so this story is written from the point
of view of the data point you you got
that
um and so already where are we you know
like what how is our encounter with data
when we actually are following data on
its own adventure to go from you know
the light got turned on to I need to be
in a server Farm in Arizona you know
and then like the story unfolds I don't
know who has that book right now but the
story unfolds and I might um give you
the punch but this one data point that
we're following in this story turns out
that she was one of the data points that
was like really off in the time
um in the timing and so then we are
following the parallel story of the the
women who lives in that house page in
the story who thinks that her husband is
cheating on her because this point is
off it's not supposed to be there and so
like she keeps on like turning it on and
off on and off like trying to like look
at the data point and this data Point's
like wow like I'm like cast into the
sunlight all this time it gets really
excited and then turns out it was just
like a butt dial kind of thing situation
where there was no infidelity happening
there was only this kind of like mistake
that happened and so that's the story
right but the stories are all quite
different they're stories where the data
is really there like wanting to serve
this idea of servitude is really
powerful in a lot of the stories which
give me pause because this is something
we understand very often about data
right like data we create data for our
own benefits as humans and so when this
comes back in the story there's
questions from my end of like well what
if what else can it be you know what do
data really want do they really want to
help us or can they have something else
they might be interested in some of the
stories from Josh um William um Josh
Mary Wilkinson are very cheeky and
they're very much like you thought you
were gonna have some meaning from the
story think again this is like a whole
really surrealist
poetry kind of oriented story where it's
really hard to make meaning and so
there's really something interesting to
me about this kind of data pushing back
and saying like I'm not as malleable as
you think I can have my own resistance
and then that's really becoming kind of
interesting
uh okay we a website it's called Data
epics.studio I encourage you all to look
it up that's where all 28 stories are
you can read them the data that is
associated with the stories are also
there and so you can understand you know
what produced what story
um you can if there's each author has
about four stories and you can kind of
really get into if you like a genre you
can follow it
when you go on the homepage you can
hover and see what kind of each story is
about so you can read what data it's
coming from but also you know some of
the stories are really really emotional
and really about the connection very
close connection between people and data
she is my soul you know like I don't
know if you can get deeper than that in
terms of connection
but then sometimes you get like give me
a basket of toes and you're like okay
this might be like a more of a
humoristic question how do you rob a
bank got into the story that's a very
fun one to read too and then sometimes
it's very much about the connection to
the body so Alex Madison one of the
authors was really interested in like
the conditions in which data are
produced
I was born of her breath we are both one
body and many the question of like where
the where is the limit or the boundary
between the person producing the data
and then the data itself
um so there's all these very existential
questions that also came through from
that project will I even Outlast you
you know that could be the human asking
that but that could also be the data so
there's a lot of kind of questions what
it what why do we exist to be useful is
to be free like that's also a really
weird kind of concept but really thought
provoking
okay
so
with each family or each household
um we worked on four stories and every
story took about three months to like
collect the data get the story and give
it back and so we worked with these
people for about a year and we were
really curious like okay well what's the
impact of this you know like I'm all
here saying like and this is how you
change people's minds and so well okay
what happened so that two things really
were interesting
so we met participants after every story
to ask them you know like how's it going
what did you think of the story could
you see your data could you see yourself
does it make you think about your data
differently and every time they would
say like I didn't have any expectations
for the story except uh I was really
expecting to see myself in it and you're
like this is an expectation but
um okay so there was this real desire to
see yourself in the story of course like
you're giving your story to somebody who
is going to write a story for you and
there was kind of a disconnect between
how
how that happened and there's this idea
of like the data twin right like which
is kind of common and um
HDI and also SDS this idea that data is
kind of your an extension of you and a
portrait of you and I think for this
there was it's more of a distorted twin
or like broken mirror twin that we could
see where you could get parts of it
sometimes you would see like oh my God I
did say that you know but
um I see your question uh
and but there was kind of always this
idea of like oh well I'm I'm open to
multiple things but still I want to see
glimpses of me yes
they have different data sets or like
two stories from uh from the same data
set yeah each book is a different data
set
so
um
each household has four stories
sometimes if somebody for example lived
with like only a voice assistant then
each story would come from the same
voice assistant but at different times
of the year so we you'd get like a
January one then like a March or you
know whatever and each household worked
with same author for the whole time so
they could kind of
they could sometimes recognize the style
not always and some households had
multiple devices and so we would switch
between stories and so the first story
could be a voice assistant well it could
be like a thermostat the second one
could be the smart bed the third one the
voice assistant and then the last one
made the smart home camera in those
cases we usually tried to go from like
more abstract data to more concrete so
going from like a thermostat which
basically just gives you temperature to
like an actual camera when you can see
you know what's going on on the street
in front there's different level of how
much you know really from the fam from
the household
um so yeah
yeah
and then we also ask people you know has
your relationship to data
like how's it changed over the last year
and they usually say nothing's changed
except I unplugged the Alexa and I don't
want to use it anymore
and then be like oh okay and that's not
related to the project and they were
like not really I was like okay
um so there's like uh I think what this
kind of points to actually is this
really subtle change that happens
through this project where people are
not able to pinpoint directly what's
happening and there is a
um I think because it was over such a
long period of time and there was both
the fact that we were asking them to you
know access their data was a big part of
the project so that they could send it
to us and that's not a trivial part of
the project that's actually hard to do
for many of these devices and so for
people to have to do that and then to
read the stories and US keeping on
asking I think there was a lot of
different kind of probing that was
happening through the project that had
them consider perhaps a little
differently how they are engaging with
data and so you know that wasn't the
case for all the households some of the
households were like yeah I have nothing
to hide and I still have nothing to hide
and so you know I might maintain how I
live with my data but some other
households had had some of these shifts
happen which was kind of interesting and
promising in a way for this project
part of this project is really about
building these new imaginaries so
remember this kind of image of the
Google search all the data is just blue
on this black background well in these
stories we have like so many metaphors
around aquatic things many metaphors
about the body many images around
relationships which is really
interesting and so we're actually right
now working on a dictionary of data
imaginaries that are kind of trying to
pull some of the images here and also
from our conversations with the
participants so start to build another
another palette you know like it's a
different view of what data can be or
feel like
um and then the getting closer point is
really about
it's like a pitch for imagination
basically and for fiction right so if we
if data is so hard to access and we had
to like actively support our
participants and getting their data from
their devices
imagination might be another way to
really get closer to data to really
start to think about data and to have it
as part of our everyday lives that can
open up some new doors and so
um this idea of getting closer through
imagination is um what's kind of coming
out of that project
okay questions on the data epics
yeah
I have two questions so um one in terms
of uh the writers writing the story was
there a limit in terms of uh based on
who was reading it for example if kids
would be reading it versus with adults
like how they have to structure this
story and like you know obviously the
addiction that they could use what type
of readings were allowed uh that's my
first question yeah
um so we worked with households where
they're
were
the stories were not for the kids
so two households have kids but the
stores were not for them
um basically because that wasn't the I
think it would be a very different
project if that was the angle we wanted
to take and so we targeted adults
instead
um and so there weren't any
that wasn't really anything that was
like completely off the table in terms
of what they could write
um so there's a range of things that
happened in the stories
um there we gave them kind of a ballpark
word we said it's a short story
and a kind of a ballpark word count but
it really varied like some of them are
much longer than others
um and we gave the authors a few prompts
so we gave them the data we told them
what they what the Visa was coming from
we gave them no information about the
households at all like who lives there
how many people what kind of house it is
we
quiet
but we gave them because we wanted to
really support kind of these other
perspectives on data and we gave them a
few excerpts of reading that cast data
slightly differently so one of the
stories we gave them kind of images of
data centers just to say like hey like
data is not completely immaterial like
it actually exists in some places and we
gave them one of them was really about
the kind of the relation to the human
body and so some of the those themes are
kind of coming back through
um yeah I expanded on your question
well found these things they didn't feel
like
um
would it have I guess like changed
things or would it be different if the
authors approached it more from the
angle of using inanimate objects that
kind of treated form of like fiction
wait so still in fiction but they would
build an object or the object would be
the character I guess I
guess like they'd be personifying like
either like anything that wasn't human
beings we were living in a sense
um yeah
uh I think I see what you're getting at
so the
the store some stories did that uh some
stories were really focused on like the
the device some stories were really
focused just on the data and had no
connection to humans at all and then
some student stories had humans part of
them
um
I don't think that's what made a
difference really it was more about
sometimes it was like the world that was
created and it was kind of like do I
even know that my data is part of that
um sometimes it was about
um
trying to so yeah sometimes I was like
especially for the voice assistants
people were trying to find the phrases
they had said you know and so that was a
way for them to kind of but even when
they did so like how do you rob a bank
like of course the author doesn't have
the context for wow that why that was
said and so they have to reinvent a
whole other story to to put this in the
story and so there's kind of I think
especially the expectations were much
higher the first story because they were
like I think a lot of people were
expecting the authors to do kind of
detective work to kind of be like okay
how many people do I think exist in this
house and like what is the house I think
and like trying to rewrite their life
from the last month and that that's
impossible to do with only one data set
and so none of the authors did that
um however some of the authors actually
caught The Vibes really well and but
that felt eerie and so then it's like is
that better or not because now it's kind
of this weird kind of uncanny any Valley
of what's is this
um
how much do they really know just
through the data
yeah yeah you're welcome
yeah
what we're like the emotions associated
with not feeling represented by the
stories like was it kind of a
disappointment or I mean some of those
stories were like
you know cheating or something like did
people get upset about that just kind of
like oh
uh yeah okay so the cheating one
um the person whose data that was is a
woman who's 68 or nine and lives on her
own and doesn't have a husband and so
she just thought it was funny
um the there's another one the Peloton
data was really funny because there was
like two stories from the Peloton and in
both Stories the the human character is
like an old man but it's actually a
younger like 30-ish age women who like
that's her data and she was like
are you saying I have like the heartbeat
of an old man now like so there was
um
I I don't think it was frustration I
think it was kind of just it was
surprise and it was a little bit of a
pause I think the the reflection that
happened was more around
um
oh this isn't just about me and like oh
data has these other things that happen
to it that I never considered before
which was part of our goal so in a way
that that was
good from like a research perspective
um and I think you know as the stories
continued on people actually had less
and less expectations because they were
like I don't know what's going to happen
with this
um I think
yeah and sometimes representation wasn't
only about like you chose the wrong
character it was more of like
oh this isn't even a story that is
happening in a house you know like this
is like this data is now in the like
Transatlantic cable Under the Sea trying
to Ping to some other place and so it's
that's where there was some of that kind
of surprise that happened and sometimes
frustration
um
yeah and then some stories were like
really really metaphorical and so it was
it's almost impossible to know that the
data like what even is the data for the
story so like an example for that is the
story intelligence which is based on
Sonos data which I thought was going to
be the series of songs that people have
played turns out that's not that at all
it's basically just kind of where was
music played like when were the div when
was the service kind of accessed and
when we're so so it doesn't say very
much
um and so but that's the story where
basically intelligence says it's the
it's kind of this like long monologue
from the intelligence which is the data
kind of just basically saying like you
thought there was going to be meaning
and there's no meaning and so
that's it yeah
I guess out of this is really cool but
then like was there an expectation from
your guys's perspective of like were you
expecting the data to match kind of
these household conversions like the
people themselves you always see
yourself in like your own data like what
were you guys I thought was just
admitted a lot yeah we were not hoping
that they would see themselves actually
because the goal was really about like
the title data epics epics is really the
story of a long journey going and
discovering things and so it's really
this idea that data has their own
Adventures that we never think of and so
we were hoping for these stories to be
far away you know like the Odyssey
type
um so
so that was our intention of course then
like when your participants are like we
have to do this three more times
and then like you could you're
questioning a little bit like okay well
is this the right thing and then like
keep going so
um that's for that part of the question
and then the other side of your question
uh we before doing this we had an
interview study where uh kind of like
contextual inquiry study where we visit
pre-covet visited people's homes and
asked them show us your iot devices tell
us what data they produce show us the
data if you know how to and tell us how
you engage with it and basically what
came back was I know the data's there I
only look at it when there's a bug and
or like an accident or an incident and
um it's like a good to have kind of
thing and
if you read that paper at the end we
kind of come up with some directions or
actually for each theme we kind of
created a speculative sketch that tries
to push on the theme that we saw and so
um data epics was one of those uh and so
we but to you know to create these five
sketches we probably sketched 150 before
and then like narrow narrow now you know
like the design process from a lot to
just a few
um and so yeah the day diet picks was
like a Post-It called Data epics and
then we were like we should try it and
then here we are yeah okay one more
question and then I'll have more things
I want to show yeah in terms of
um the participants you said that even
though the intention was like
um
or kind of have data have drawn its own
epic wouldn't it change things
in your opinion if um they were the ones
getting the prompts where whether it was
keywords like oh I'd like to see my
theater represented this way like more
of a connection with the users oh yeah
for sure because then you know like then
they're giving like creative direction
to the writer I think it would have
changed completely the experience for
the writers because now they really
because I think in this scenario they
felt like perhaps like we were the
client more than the reader
um
but if it's like the the
reader is giving you like I want this in
the style of a murder mystery then you
know like then it's a really different
kind of experience and it's a really
different ask on the on the on the
friction wider what we wanted was really
to tap into the imaginative capacity of
the writers and that's why we wanted
them to kind of go in the direction they
wanted and the prompts were not about
the type of story they were more of like
here's a little information about data
and we did that because
um we did a pilot study before I do it
so we did like a set of four stories and
then we did the 24 others and in that
first set we didn't give any prompts but
the author told us that you know like
she had to go and watch the Magic Bus
episode on data with her kids to like
figure out how data Works to be able to
write the story and we're like wow okay
like I get the hint that like maybe we
could support better
um and so
yeah
yes do the writers have any awareness of
like who they were writing for or was
that oh sweet okay full Secret
and then at the end
the stories were done and when the
website was finished we did a public
launch of the website where we invited
all the writers they
um did a live reading of one of their
stories and we invited the participants
back so that was the first time they met
and not all the participants were able
to make it and uh six out of the seven
authors were there but the ones that met
it was like a it was a weird moment and
like I was really excited because like
we knew you know at the research team we
knew both sides and we're like oh my god
when they need this gonna be you're
sitting in the corner oh yes definitely
try to not be too creepy yeah uh okay I
have 10 minutes
um
I'll show you stuff quickly
stop me when you want okay the ad
interpreters is
um
a set of devices that also cast data
differently there's three of them the
middle one is the data Bakery which
transforms data into cookie recipes for
you to bake and then eat your data most
of the recipes are terrible
um broadcast
is picking up on traffic that your Alexa
is so when Alexa is sending and
receiving data that's data traffic and
so broadcast it just lets you know like
hey data's moving around the main thing
that happened with that project is that
in a very naive way I and our research
team thought that data is only moving
around when you're talking to Alexa not
true
um of course there's always these like
is there an update you know it's keeping
making sure it's on the network so
this was a sound project
so
these are some of the sounds that we've
represented so when data was moving
around kind of similar to the data it
picks it picks side of like what are the
adventures these were some of the sounds
we propose as like think about your data
being somewhere else
some of it was trying to be about you
know how does how does data sound like
when it's moving and then where does it
go
the data is always kind of so we thought
there's only going to be a few Peaks and
that's how that's how we made our kind
of interaction model which is any time
data is moving there's a little kind of
blank and sometimes it can make some
noise for you to catch the Sounds by
turning that ball but now I can do that
in the night and wake you up so that
wasn't Our intention but that happens
now
so yes big uh summary iot data have
connections Way Beyond the home and then
it has an impact back when it you know
when it's in your home okay soft fading
is one project where we really were
trying to
um
turn the idea of data up on on its head
and so instead of thinking about data as
digital really thinking about it that's
completely analog and only material and
so basically what it is is that it's the
cylinder with fabric that was dyed with
turmeric but not fixed which means that
it can fade over time so you know the
fabric in the beginning and then after
like five weeks if you just leave it
like that in the Sun but now it's on
that
um cylinder and it turns and so it means
that every
it turns one turn a day so every day the
same piece of fabric is exposed to the
same kind of light
so we thought this is what the fabric
would look like when you take it out
right
but then we put it in a home and we saw
this and we were like oh yeah shadows
and things and people move and you might
move it and so then there's all these
other things that happen and so this
really is about this reminder that the
way data is collected influences the
data obviously
when the first try we got this and we
were like ah what is going on what
happened turns out
um we needed a mechanical engineer on
our team to figure out how this thing
should be turning and not slipping so we
fixed it
um and then we got this so winter in
Seattle Summer in Seattle we have more
sun in the summer it's nicer
um but that's you know that was the
hypothesis pretty much but what I think
is the most interesting about this
project is this idea that there is no
record of every single day there is only
a collection because it just keeps on
adding to itself right it's like it's an
archive that keeps making itself and you
can never go to the one data point and
that to me is like a such a different
way of thinking about data and I want to
keep exploring that the other thing
that's interesting with this project is
okay after two months maybe you take it
out if you really like it and want to
pin it on your wall It's Gonna Keep On
fading
and it'll eventually disappear and so it
really opens up all these questions
about you know do we need to keep the
data why we need to keep all of our data
can we have this idea of data
disappearing and
forgetting all these questions about the
right to forget are also kind of
entangled in this project as well
okay I have uh three four minutes so
I will go I this is voices and voice
voices and voids.net I invite you to go
visit it this is a whole website just
about
um a voice assistant data 26 archives
lots of weird things on this one which I
will invite you to go see
uh that's all part of it
um but I want to get to here okay so
this is the conclusion there's a lot
there's a I think maybe six different
tips I want to share with you so
personal iot data are difficult to
access
that is one thing we need to work on if
we want people to be able to reclaim
their data and do some of that stuff for
themselves and actually access and
understand their own data they need to
have access
it's hard some of these projects during
the data ethics some devices and
services changed how you access data
multiple times so we had to rewrite the
instructions for participants multiple
times and we like we're pretty good at
this and man you know for people who are
not familiar with that that's really
hard
data engagements and encounters don't
have to be based in productivity or
functionality I hope I showed that today
imagining might be our best way to get
closer to data and so this is a big
pitch for imagination as a way of
knowing also
data materialization or physicalization
is a subjective act I showed you that
very clearly I think with the listening
cups but that's also true for any other
ways we work with data when we do a
visualization we might be more used to
it but it's still a subjective act the
way we decide how to represent data and
that comes with
control and power and we have to be
careful about how we use that
matters of Labor intimacy everyday life
surveillance capitalism temporality and
creative potential are all entangled in
iot data and I just really like seeing
these words side by side as things that
exist together there
it does come down to an intelligible
question which is what is it like to be
with data what is our life with data and
what should it be and for whom and who
decides a lot of questions
um okay
in and then this is I think the last few
the last two in making data
materialization we are not only shaping
people's understanding of that data
right that thing that happened that
event but we're also shaping their view
of what data is and what counts as data
and I think that's really powerful to
think about that right like there's kind
of the like Hands-On like this is your
story based on your Peloton story but
now also maybe you think about data in
general as a different thing
okay so many students have been part of
these projects so many of them
undergrads and so many of them grads and
I have to say Thank you so here they are
also thank you to the many very generous
funders for these projects
um and thank you for being here and I'm
happy to take more questions also feel
free to reach out
um yeah that's it